non
la commune isabelle est une dame très
respectable elle est mère de trois
enfants est maire d'une grande ville de
trois cent mille habitants
gérard est agriculteur apprécié de tous
il à 22h et il est maire de son village
de 68 habitants isabelle et gérard ont
la même fonction
le même titre quasiment les mêmes
pouvoirs mais évidemment pas le même
budget ils sont maire de leur commune
mais leur vie est bien différente gérard
connaît tous ses administrés par leur
prénom
il s'est en quelque la cie sont tous les
enfants de sa commune isabelle n'en
connais que quelques-uns il y a même
certaines rues de sa ville qu'elle n'a
jamais emprunté la commune est le plus
petit échelon administratif de france
elle est née en 1789 au moment de la
révolution
avant on l'appelait la paroisse et c'est
pour ça que la france vieux pays compte
presque autant de communes que d'églises
et de clochers
il y à 36000 communes en france une des
moins peuplée chateauvieux les fossés se
trouve dans le doubs elle n'a que sept
habitants la plus peuplée c'est paris
avec deux millions d'habitants
le maire et le président du conseil
municipal il est élu pour six ans et
c'est certainement l'élu le plus
populaire de france parce que ses
attributions sont liés à notre vie
quotidienne
le maire est aussi officier d'état civil
c'est à dire qu'il est responsable de
l'enregistrement officiel et du décompte
de tous les français qui naissent se
marient et meurt dans sa commune il est
responsable également du permis de
construire et du cadastre le cadastre
c'est comme l'état civil mais pour les
territoires ce qui permet à gérard de
savoir que son pommier au fond de son
jardin et bien chez lui et pas chez son
voisin la commune entretient les écoles
primaire communale elle s'occupe de la
propreté de la ville avec 40 camions
bennes et des dizaines d'engins qui
arpentent la ville d'isabelle avec deux
ballets et une boîte que le cantonnier
habitants du village de gérard utilisent
pour l'unique trottoir de la rue
principale
gérard se préoccupe de l'absence de
commerces dans son village
quand isabelle tente de convaincre des
patrons chinois d'investir dans son
nouveau quartier d'affaires
ce samedi isabelle marie quatre couples
et ses adjoints 12 autres dans une
deuxième salle des fêtes de la mairie
gérard lui marie la fille de l'ancienne
épicière avec un garçon de paris ils
vont s'installer dans le village pour
reprendre l'épicerie locale qui fera
aussi bureau de poste pour lutter contre
la désertification
depuis quelques temps les communes se
rassemblent entre elles et partagent
leurs équipements on appelle ça
l'intercommunalité
je vous en parle dans un autre épisode
cette année gérard et isabelle se sont
rencontrés au congrès des maires de
france où les élus se tiennent au
courant des dernières lois à la buvette
ils ont parlé de leur travail de maire
et les prochaines municipales gérard élu
depuis 29 ans voudrait bien passer la
main mais personne ne veut le remplacer
alors qu'isabelle commence une campagne
incertaine contre huit autres listes
isabelle et gérard porte fièrement leur
écharpe tricolore
ils représentent chacun un 36 millièmes
du formidable maillage démocratique et
communale de la france